Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour,
c'est votre émission parlementaire
de fin de semaine.
On va revoir les séquences fortes
à l'Assemblée et au Sénat avec
notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart: On accueille
cette semaine Jean-François
Husson.
Vous êtes sénateur Républicains de
Meurthe-et-Moselle.
- Kathia Gilder: Les sénateurs ont
voté la première partie du budget,
le volet recettes.
Une version modifiée en faveur des
collectivités locales.
Le Sénat a refusé de taxer les
superprofits.
Les compagnies pétrolières et les
autres compagnies ayant engrangé
de gros bénéfices.
Le droit à l'IVG a été voté à
l'Assemblée pour être inscrit dans
la Constitution.
Il faut encore l'aval du Sénat.
Une question sur l'affaire
McKinsey.
- Alexandre Poussart: Elle fait
beaucoup parler.
Le parquet national financier a
ouvert deux informations
judiciaires sur les relations
entre certaines sociétés de
conseil et le président de la
République.
L'une pour financement illégal des
campagnes de 2017 et 2022 et
l'autre pour favoritisme dans
l'obtention de certains marchés
publics.
Jean-François Husson, comment vous
réagissez à cette affaire?
- Jean-François Husson: Ca
pourrait être un sparadrap sur la
tête de la majorité
présidentielle.
Il faut laisser la justice faire
son travail.
On voit bien que les travaux qui
ont été menés et conduits par mes
collègues, à travers la commission
d'enquête, non seulement avaient
mis au jour un certain nombre de
situations particulières, et vous
voyez qu'il n'y a pas...
Il y a une corrélation et une
suite...
Laissons faire la justice.
Il faut être vigilant.
Il faut être attentif dans toutes
les républiques et les
démocraties.
Il faut faire attention à séparer
les pouvoirs et les liens avec le
monde économique.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce sparadrap
peut-il fragiliser le mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron?
- Jean-François Husson: Il est
trop tôt pour le dire.
Il y a toujours un risque.
- Alexandre Poussart: On évoque le
gros dossier de la semaine.
L'examen du budget 2023.
Les collectivités territoriales
font face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie.
- Défendre les moyens des
collectivités face à la crise,
voilà le mot d'ordre du Sénat.
C'est l'enveloppe que l'Etat verse
chaque année aux collectivités.
Le gouvernement l'a porté à près
de 27 milliards d'euros en 2023.
C'est insuffisant pour les
sénateurs qui veulent indexer
cette dotation sur l'inflation.
- C'est un manque à gagner de
l'ordre de 4 milliards d'euros.
Sur la trajectoire que nous
connaissons, ces pertes pourraient
monter jusqu'à 10 milliards
d'euros entre 2022 et 2027.
Ce manque à gagner est intolérable
pour les collectivités.
Elles doivent remettre en cause la
capacité d'action.
- Une indexation votée contre
l'avis du gouvernement.
La majorité est divisée sur la
suppression de la taxe sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises au
profit des collectivités.
Elle devait être remplacée par une
part de TVA dans le projet du
gouvernement.
La droite sénatoriale, favorable à
cette mesure qui soutient les
entreprises, voulait la repousser
d'un an.
Le Sénat l'a supprimée par une
alliance des centristes et de la
gauche.
- Vous faites un cadeau
supplémentaire aux grandes
entreprises.
Les TPE ne payent pas cette taxe.
Vous transférez la charge du
financement des collectivités sur
les ménages qui payent la TVA.
- Il faut faire face à la crise et
à l'augmentation des prix.
Il faut redresser les finances.
- Pour aider les communes face à
la crise de l'énergie, le Sénat a
élargi le filet de sécurité,
prolongé en 2023: il prévoit que
l'Etat prenne en charge la moitié
des dépenses énergétiques des
communes les plus en difficulté.
Les sénateurs ont voté l'extension
du dispositif pour que les
communes en bénéficient.
- J'aimerais pouvoir dire que
l'Etat peut compenser l'essentiel
de l'augmentation de la facture
des collectivités et des
entreprises.
Mais je mentirais en le disant.
- Le Sénat a voté une baisse de la
TVA sur les transports collectifs
afin de contenir la hausse des
tarifs pour les usagers.
- Alexandre Poussart: Une majorité
de sénateurs de gauche ont rejeté
la réforme de compétitivité
d'Emmanuel Macron, à savoir la
suppression de l'impôt pour les
entreprises.
Vous regrettez le rejet de cette
réforme?
- Jean-François Husson: Bien sûr.
La réforme devait se faire en
plusieurs temps.
C'était notre proposition.
D'abord, parce qu'il s'agit de 8
milliards.
La France est, en Europe, médaille
d'argent sur le poids des
prélèvements obligatoires, juste
derrière le Danemark.
On a un déficit de compétitivité.
La mesure doit produire 8
milliards de baisses d'impôts.
Nous avions proposé un accord en
deux temps, d'abord en décalant
d'un an la prise d'effet de cette
réforme, et surtout parce que le
plus important, c'était, en
contrepartie de cet accord, une
compensation bien pensée et sur
laquelle les collectivités
donnaient leur accord.
Aujourd'hui, le dispositif n'est
pas abouti.
Pendant deux ans, on a proposé
qu'il y ait un dégrèvement.
L'effet était neutre pour les
collectivités territoriales.
Cela permet au gouvernement de
bien travailler et préparer sa
copie.
Les collectivités locales ont bien
en mémoire le problème de la taxe
d'habitation et les conditions
dans lesquelles elle a été
annulée.
- Kathia Gilder: Une question plus
politique sur ces sénateurs
centristes que l'on a vus à
certains moments de l'examen du
budget s'allier avec la gauche.
Vous sentez que la majorité de
droite et du centre au Sénat est
divisée?
- Jean-François Husson: Non.
Nous en avions discuté entre nous.
Les sénateurs centristes ont une
position différente sur ce sujet.
Ils considèrent que ce n'est pas
le moment.
Chacun peut porter son propre
jugement sur la temporalité.
Je partage une priorité absolue
avec les sénateurs centristes.
La première des priorités, c'est
de permettre à la France de faire
face à la crise énergétique.
Autant pour les Français que pour
les entreprises.
Le monde économique va
certainement affronter de grosses
turbulences avec cette crise
énergétique.
Les collectivités locales sont le
poumon de l'investissement public
en France.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat a
voté une hausse de plus de 1
milliard d'euros de la dotation de
l'Etat versée aux collectivités.
C'est un alignement sur
l'inflation.
Vous étiez contre ce coup de pouce
supplémentaire.
Pourquoi?
- Jean-François Husson: Je viens
de l'expliquer.
Nous allons devoir mobiliser des
moyens exceptionnels.
Tout cela, pour faire face à la
crise énergétique.
Il y a une revalorisation des
bases, c'est-à-dire la valeur et
le produit des impôts qui sont
aujourd'hui importants et
conséquents.
Je préfère prendre le pari de ne
pas indexer l'inflation.
Je ne veux pas dégrader les
comptes publics.
- Kathia Gilder: Les sénateurs ont
élargi le filet de sécurité pour
aider les communes à payer les
factures d'énergie qui explosent
et qui vont continuer d'exploser
avec l'amortisseur électricité qui
va venir en soutien des
entreprises et des collectivités.
Ca coûtera environ 12 milliards
d'euros.
Vous y êtes favorable?
- Jean-François Husson: Il y a un
point d'interrogation et un
préalable.
Une enveloppe d'un dispositif dont
je ne connais pas le calcul, je me
méfie par principe.
Il faut avoir très vite les
éléments.
Le plus tôt possible.
Je viens de lire dans la presse
qu'on allait nous communiquer les
éléments.
Dans ces cas-là, on vote à
l'aveugle.
Hier après-midi, au moment du vote
de la première partie du budget,
j'ai alerté le ministre des
Comptes publics en disant que le
président de la commission des
finances et moi-même allions lui
demander rapidement à être mis au
courant.
Nous ferons des points
trimestriels, y compris avec nos
prérogatives de rapporteur et de
président, sur les contrôles sur
pièces et sur place.
Le sujet est trop important.
Sur le filet de sécurité, il faut
être au rendez-vous.
Par rapport au dispositif qui
était insuffisant, notamment.
Quelle est la philosophie?
Il faut quelque chose de simple,
clair et juste.
Toutes les collectivités doivent
pouvoir prétendre, en fonction de
l'évolution des dépenses sur leur
budget, à ce filet.
Il n'y a plus aucun seuil.
On enlève tout.
Ce filet de sécurité intervient
après l'amortisseur électricité,
il va donc toucher toutes les
énergies.
Simple, clair et juste.
C'est pour tout le monde.
Ca tient dans le budget.
- Alexandre Poussart: Dans
l'examen de ce budget, il y a eu
le débat sur la taxe des
superprofits générés par certains
groupes durant cette période
d'inflation.
Les sénateurs de droite ont rejeté
cette idée de taxe sur les
superprofits.
La taxe était proposée par une
alliance entre les sénateurs de
gauche et les sénateurs
centristes.
- Le problème est politique.
Est-ce qu'on considère qu'il y a
des profits exceptionnels à un
moment donné?
Oui, on les taxe même au niveau
européen.
Qu'ils soient nationaux ou
européens, on les reconnaît.
On préfère se planquer derrière
les Allemands et les autres qui
eux, dès le mois de juillet, ont
organisé des contributions
nationales.
Les Espagnols, les Italiens, les
Anglais...
Ce ne sont pourtant pas des
marxistes léninistes.
- Kathia Gilder: Taxer les
superprofits, est-ce que ça ne
relève pas du bon sens?
- Jean-François Husson: Si,
mais...
Je veux parler de la contribution
inframarginale.
C'est borné par rapport au prix
des énergies.
Au-delà d'un certain montant, tout
ce que les secteurs d'énergie font
comme bénéfices
est repris par l'Etat.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous êtes d'accord
avec l'idée d'une contribution ?
- Jean-François Husson:
C'est ce qui se passe.
On veut faire payer
aux énergéticiens,
y compris celles et ceux...
Les fournisseurs alternatifs
qui, dans le marché libéralisé,
avaient pris des parts de marché
et qui ont pris
la poudre d'escampette
quand ils ont vu
qu'ils perdaient de l'argent.
C'est prévu dans le dispositif,
qui a été voté
d'aller,
à partir du 1er juillet 2022,
rechercher ce qu'ils ont fait
comme bénéfices exceptionnels.
- Alexandre Poussart: Donc pas
besoin de créer une autre taxe.
La semaine prochaine,
les sénateurs vont examiner
les dépenses de l'Etat,
des ministères.
Quels seront les points
de modification importants
de la majorité du Sénat?
On parle du budget de l'écologie.
- Jean-François Husson: On en aura
sur le plan de relance
qui touche à sa fin, on en aura
même sur le budget travail,
autour des formations,
des milliards mal dépensés,
une réforme autour
de France compétences
qui est une réforme mal financée,
non financée alors qu'elle a été
mise en place
dans le quinquennat précédent,
qu'elle devait apporter
des réponses.
Nous sommes pour une écologie de
l'efficacité, de la bonne dépense
pour permettre la transition.
On aura l'occasion d'aborder...
Cette espèce d'ineptie qui fait
que lorsqu'on encourage la
conversion des véhicules
thermiques au profit des véhicules
dits propres, on favorise
l'importation de véhicules
produits en dehors de l'Europe.
Les Français nous envoient depuis
un certain temps des messages.
Il faut accélérer et permettre
d'acheter aux Français des
véhicules à portée de bourse,
produits en Europe et si possible
en France.
Il faut renforcer ce lien de
proximité.
Il faut que ces efforts de
transition soient utiles pour
l'économie française et le
contribuable.
- Alexandre Poussart: La majorité
du Sénat pourrait diminuer le
budget alloué à l'écologie?
- Jean-François Husson: Oui.
Il y a une alerte à donner.
Je suis conscient du message que
nous envoyons.
Il y a eu trop de gaspillage.
- Kathia Gilder: Les députés
examinaient les 12 propositions de
loi et propositions de La France
Insoumise au titre de leur ordre
du jour réservé.
Une séance polémique.
Les députés de la majorité ont été
mis en minorité sur un texte qui
prévoyait la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés.
Le débat a été interrompu dans la
nuit.
- Vous êtes contents d'avoir pu
trouver une petite mesquinerie
pour ne pas laisser une niche et
aller jusqu'au bout.
Tu vas la fermer!
- Non, ce n'est pas possible.
C'est une invective.
Cher collègue, on ne peut pas en
venir aux invectives.
- Kathia Gilder: Qu'en
pensez-vous?
- Jean-François Husson: Je suis
consterné.
Ca renvoie une mauvaise image de
nos enceintes parlementaires.
Comment voulez-vous recevoir
ensuite un message de sérieux sur
certains sujets, de gravité?
On ne parle pas dans une enceinte
parlementaire comme on parle chez
soi ou au café du commerce.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est indigne
d'un élu de la République, pour
vous?
- Jean-François Husson: C'est une
question d'éducation et de
respect.
Il faut apprendre à se maîtriser.
- Alexandre Poussart: Même la
majorité présidentielle dans ce
débat a fait de l'obstruction pour
éviter que le texte sur la
réintégration des soignants non
vaccinés soit voté.
- Jean-François Husson: C'est
difficile d'être serein.
Vous offrez des angles d'attaque à
diverses oppositions qui viennent
toutes forcément appuyer sur des
points faibles.
Il faut maîtriser l'ordre du jour.
Il faut s'organiser.
Ca ne grandit pas nos assemblées
ni le débat politique.
Il y a la volonté d'aller chercher
des sujets qui font le buzz,
première erreur.
On n'est pas là pour être...
Il faut arrêter cette
instantanéité permanente pour
faire le buzz pendant 48 heures
puis passer à autre chose.
Il y a de grands sujets qui
préoccupent les Français et
l'opinion publique.
Il faut être plus serein.
Il faut de la sérénité.
C'est un des fondamentaux sur
lesquels nous devons passer le
débat public.
- Kathia Gilder: Un autre texte
concernait l'inscription du droit
à l'IVG dans la Constitution.
Il a été voté à une large
majorité.
La proposition de loi a été
adoptée en première lecture à
l'Assemblée avec le soutien de la
majorité.
- Un hémicycle presque unanime.
Une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle largement votée.
L'Assemblée a adopté l'entrée dans
la Constitution de l'IVG.
- Je suis très émue de ce vote et
de ce signal historique que
l'Assemblée a envoyé à toutes les
femmes de notre pays, mais aussi à
l'ensemble des femmes du monde.
- La loi garantit l'effectivité et
l'égal accès à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse.
Il aura fallu plusieurs heures de
débats pour aboutir à ce résultat.
Les groupes de la NUPES et de la
majorité étaient favorables à ce
texte.
La droite et l'extrême droite
étaient divisées sur la nécessité
de protéger ce droit.
Marine Le Pen a défendu l'entrée
dans la Constitution des articles
du code de la santé publique
régissant l'avortement, tout en
affirmant qu'il n'était pas en
danger.
- Pas un seul mouvement politique
en France n'est pour le retrait de
cette possibilité pour les femmes.
- Aurore Bergé a annoncé qu'elle
retirait sa proposition de loi
ayant le même objectif.
- Ce texte devient le texte de
notre Assemblée, un texte qui doit
tous nous réunir, un texte qui
doit aboutir.
Nous ne devons pas finir notre
mandat parlementaire sans que la
Constitution ait été modifiée.
- Le droit à l'avortement n'est
pas encore entré dans notre loi
fondamentale.
Il va falloir convaincre le Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: Tous les regards
se tournent donc vers le Sénat.
Il faut que cette proposition soit
votée dans les mêmes termes au
Sénat.
Est-ce que les sénateurs
empêcheront l'acception du droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution?
- Jean-François Husson: Il n'y a
pas de problème en France.
On a la loi Veil qui protège et
garantit le droit à l'avortement,
la liberté de la femme de pouvoir
décider.
Quel est le fond du sujet?
C'est la recherche du buzz
médiatique de mettre en
difficulté...
- Kathia Gilder: Le vote assez
large de cette proposition...
- Jean-François Husson: Mais non!
Aux Etats-Unis, il y a un
problème.
C'est à l'Etat fédéral de juger.
C'est le juge qui décide de ce
sujet.
En France, il y a accord total.
C'est un non-sujet.
Il n'y a pas besoin d'inscrire
dans la loi constitutionnelle ce
droit.
Le Sénat a eu déjà l'occasion il y
a quelques semaines de se
prononcer.
C'était sur un texte similaire.
Il faut appréhender ce sujet de
manière apaisée.
Le rapport sénatorial l'a annoncé.
Il y a quelques problèmes, mais ce
n'est pas un problème de droit.
Ce sont parfois des problèmes de
pratiques.
Il faut y remédier.
- Kathia Gilder: Ca ne relève pas
de la Constitution?
- Jean-François Husson: Il faut
rester serein.
Il faut arrêter de se faire
bousculer par des démarches à
contretemps.
Une démocratie apaisée, sereine et
solide sur ses bases.
- Alexandre Poussart: La droite
sénatoriale qui rejette
l'inscription de dans la
Constitution, ça fait penser à une
droite ringarde, dit la gauche.
- Jean-François Husson: Je ne sens
pas la ringardise.
Je ne dis pas que la loi Veil est
ringarde.
J'ai beaucoup de respect pour
cette grande dame, dont on a vu à
l'époque la forte émotion.
Elle montre qu'il y a des valeurs
d'humanisme, de tolérance,
d'attention aux situations les
plus fragiles.
Et notamment sur le droit des
femmes.
Tout ça a été protégé par une très
grande dame.
Ce n'est pas pour rien que la
France n'a pas bougé son
dispositif.
Ca a été garanti par le Conseil
constitutionnel à plusieurs
reprises par la suite.
Quand on est garant politiquement
et qu'on a une garantie par le
juge du droit, je crois qu'il faut
sérénité, calme et droiture.
- Kathia Gilder: Une question
rapide.
Une autre enquête du parquet
national financier qui concerne le
cumul d'emplois.
Beaucoup de responsables LR
estiment que le parquet national
financier est une juridiction
d'exception.
Ca concerne l'ex-femme d'Eric
Ciotti.
- Jean-François Husson: Un certain
nombre d'élus se sont livrés à des
pratiques...
Ca a eu lieu à l'époque.
Je vais me garder de tout
jugement.
Je ne suis pas...
Faire un jugement abrupt,
politique, quand on ne connaît pas
les tenants et les aboutissants,
je vais dire joker.
C'est par méconnaissance du point
particulier.
- Alexandre Poussart: On passe à
l'agenda du Parlement.
Au Sénat, la semaine prochaine
sera consacrée à la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi de
finances 2023.
- Kathia Gilder: Les députés se
pencheront sur l'ordre du jour,
réservé aux députés LR.
Cinq textes seront en examen,
notamment sur l'expulsion des
étrangers délinquants.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette émission.